what's the number one reason we
procrastinate is it because we want to
have you ever heard of the law of
secondary gain so think about this for
just a minute when you procrastinate
is there a benefit think of a secondary
benefit pay close attention
is it possible that when we
procrastinate
maybe
we're protecting ourselves
have you ever thought about that when i
procrastinate maybe i'm protecting
myself and so the question is protecting
myself from what
when i procrastinate maybe
i'm not doing what i need to do or want
to do i get that but maybe i'm also
protecting myself the question is
protecting myself from what
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that's holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only john assaraf
enjoy
so think about this when we
procrastinate a secondary benefit
could be
that we are
fearful of let's say being embarrassed
i'll give you a couple of examples so if
i take the action that i need to take or
want to take whether it's asking for a
raise whether it's
leaving my job and trying to find
something new leaving a relationship i'm
not happy in um uh going across the room
and asking a man or a woman what their
name is um
starting you know a new career
doing something sometimes has
known and unknown consequences
associated with it so
if we are afraid that if we take action
and the action doesn't result
in the desired outcome that we want
is it possible
that the fear of failing or the fear of
disappointing yourself or the fear of
being embarrassed or the fear of being
ashamed or the fear of being ridiculed
or the fear of disappointing yourself
one more time or the fear of losing
money is it possible that when your
subconscious mind okay is processing the
potential consequences
of the behavior
is it possible that as a protective
mechanism
we procrastinate is it possible that
hold on our 100 billion dollar bio
computer
100 billion by computer what i call is
the
frankenstein's monster part of the brain
right is it possible
that that part of the brain is causing
the behavior
we
call procrastination right so is it
possible that procrastination is
in many cases a secondary gain mechanism
to protect us
so we want to do what we want to do the
behavior but our brain is always
processing what is the potential
negative consequence
now or in the future and if
we deem that there's any
chance of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed judged disappointed failure
loss
pain discomfort any of those types of
potential feelings potential results
causes us to do what to put the brakes
on motivation the motive for the action
put the brakes on behavior the motor
cortex in the brain and then what do we
do
we then go do something else that we
feel is safer and easier for us
because
we already know what that behavior will
give us and usually we will move towards
something pleasurable something that's
common something that we've always done
at the end of
your day or week do you ever find
yourself
worried or frustrated because no matter
how much effort you put in to work and
no matter how hard you work your
financial situation
and your financial future may never seem
to be improving you might be finding
yourself living paycheck to paycheck
right now with not a lot of breathing
room and i would imagine no
discretionary income or even time to
spend on the little things that really
would make your life more enjoyable
well what i can share with you is you're
not alone that's number one and in most
cases
the real problem
is not your current circumstances
what the real problem is that most
people repeat the same
patterns of thought
and behaviors over and over again
and that is the cause
of what more of the same results but
they are looking for different results
and so today i'm going to show you how
to break that pattern break that cycle
now you see
when you think of your results your
results are effects and so the question
is effects of what
and the answer is your results are all
effects of what you believe to be true
about yourself what you believe to be
true that is possible
and it also comes down to what are your
daily habits now
if you think about what you believe and
if you think about your habits that is
what is causing the effect that you may
not like right now and so a simple
logical thing to do would be to
understand that if i could change my
beliefs about what was possible and what
was possible for me specifically and i
could create more empowering habits
then my result will change
and what i love to focus on having done
an enormous amount of brain research
over the last 10 years
is something called your inner game
and your inner game
is comprised of obviously your beliefs
your attitude your perceptions how you
see the world
and your inner game is also comprised of
what causes you to take action
and so let me share just a little story
with you that may help you understand
what i mean
about two years ago i was at a seminar
and when i got off the stage this woman
started walking towards me and i can see
she was somewhere in her you know 50s
maybe early 60s she looked nice she was
a vibrant woman she was walking right
towards me and i saw tears streaming
down her eyes
and when she got through the crowd
for a moment i thought that maybe there
was something wrong but she actually had
tears of joy in her eyes
and when i met her her name was joni
sanderson and this was in perth
australia
and she came up to me she said thank you
so much and i go well for what she says
well
about a year ago i heard you speak about
beliefs
and habits and mastering my emotions and
really working on my self-worth
and she said to me that she was a
caregiver and that she loved helping
families who needed
extra assistance for their aging parents
or for their children who may need some
additional help in the home so she was a
wonderful caregiver
but she was living on a widow's pension
of about 12 000 aussie dollars a year
and so she really didn't have enough
money to be able to take the care of her
grandkids that she wanted to to be able
to take her children on a vacation and
so i shared with her why do you think
that you're only earning twelve thousand
dollars a year and she said i don't know
and when i shared with her that she
possibly believed that that's what she
was worth
and she said to me i think i'm worth
more i said well you might be able to
declare that you're worth more but if at
a deeper level
of your brain
you have this feeling that maybe you're
not smart enough or not good enough or
not worthy enough
that is what is going to drive your
behavior
and so what i helped joanie do
prior to her coming to me and being in
gratitude was i helped her recognize
that beliefs drive behavior beliefs
drive emotions habits drive behavior and
in order to change your results living
paycheck to paycheck being stressed out
worrying about your future or even your
present circumstances right now
why not focus on working on the neural
patterns the beliefs and habits that are
nothing more than patterns in the brain
that drive 96 to 98 of your behavior and
so she started to work on what i call a
belief and habit modification program
and while she did this she started to
see herself in a different light she
started to feel
more confident more certain and more
empowered and what i can share with you
is she at that moment told me that she
went from making twelve thousand dollars
a year as a widow's from a widow's
pension and living paycheck to paycheck
to being able to charge for her services
as she was making 75 000
a year a lot of athletes you know have
this term around the a game and
showing up and doing their absolute best
mentally emotionally physically
spiritually etc
and
it got me thinking
about do you even know what your a game
is do you know what your a game is like
what
has to happen in order for you to be at
your best to play at your best
is it a routine
is it a diet
is it a way of thinking is it planning
what is it
that would cause you to play your a game
and so here's just a little
maybe task for you to consider
take 10 minutes
and ask yourself this question
in order for me to play to be at my best
here are the things that need to happen
and just make a list of what are the
things that need to happen i know for me
for example i have routines i have
routines in the morning i've got
routines in the evening
and my routines
give me the best opportunity to feel my
best and to do the things that are gonna
give me the greatest results that i want
and so i've discovered that most people
never think of this and so that's your
task for today is
what has to happen in order for you to
have a great day and create a list for
one great day
what has to happen in the morning in the
afternoon and the evening so think about
thoughts emotions feelings
and behaviors
and also think about exercise
diet and nutrition think about
meditation think about anything that
could help you have an a game day
and then go and do it hey there great
day to you i was uh just talking to a
friend of mine in london while i was
doing a little bit of a workout this
morning here at the house
and
it dawned on me to ask you this question
because i asked him this
i said how's your health plan working
how is your income producing plan
working
how is your
managing your budget working plan how is
your spiritual
awareness plan working how is your
business growth plan working how is your
career enhancement plan working
and he shared with me that uh
he doesn't have a plan
and this is a dear friend i've known for
a while
and so i asked i said without a plan
what do you expect to happen
and obviously he got the point but it
also made me aware
one of the things that i just learned
how to do
that i think
is a key factor in my success is for
whatever goal i want to achieve i create
a plan it doesn't matter how
simple it is it doesn't have to be
complex but
i create a plan uh here's what i'm going
to do
or here's the goal right and the vision
of the outcome of that goal and how it
feels and looks and
who i'm impacting and how it's going to
make me feel
and then i just had a really simple plan
to get it started what am i going to do
on monday tuesday wednesday thursday
friday saturday sunday
put into my calendar and just do it
it doesn't have to be that difficult but
in the absence of a plan
then there's too many variables that can
get in the way it's like you know being
on a
on a boat over here and you want to go
you know somewhere
you know like hawaii which is about
eight hours that way you don't have a a
plan of where you're going to be in a
day
in two days in three hours so
ask yourself what's your plan
why not put together just a simple plan
for inner sizing to strengthen your
mindset your emotional skills your focus
your awareness
put a plan together
for
the actions required
to achieve your goals
and just start but be consistent right
consistency is one of the keys to
success
what if every day
when you woke up
okay
you did this you write out
okay
on a sheet of paper on your computer
all right i'm so happy and grateful for
the fact that i am now earning i'm so
happy and grateful for the fact that i
am now earning and put a number there
i'm now earning
whatever let's say you're making 10 000
whether it's a day a week or a month i'm
not earning twenty thousand dollars
okay i'm not earning and then
in the very next step you started to see
yourself
earning that amount of money you started
to see yourself and how you felt you
start to see yourself
and how many people you would impact you
started to see yourself as you upgraded
your knowledge and your skills and you
developed you started to feel proud you
started to feel
in
alignment with
making that amount of money okay so you
started to visualize why because
visualization is simulation and you
start to fire off the neurons in your
brain
right you start to fire off the neurons
in your brain the neurons that fire
together will wire together that's part
one
then
what would you need to believe what
would you need to believe
all right in order
to earn twice as much money what would
you need to believe about yourself
right what would you need to
um to think and then
what would you need to do that day
right that week that month
right so in my trunk
uh when you set a goal like you just
said i'm sorry now running two trillion
dollar company when you set that goal
and you haven't built a million dollar
company your brain deletes it because it
it activates the uncertainty and fear
centers so set a goal that's just
outside of your comfort zone
all right just outside of your comfort
zone that scares you a little bit but
also
encourages you and inspires you so what
would you need to believe what would you
need to do what would you need
to think and then what skills would you
need to upgrade
whose help would you need in order to
make that a reality so we go from
ideation or imagination we go from
ideation and imagination which is the
einstein part of the brain all right and
then we ask ourselves all those other
questions so that now we could put
a path towards that people are focusing
on all the reasons why it's hard and
difficult
and they're not focusing on remembering
that there are hundreds of millions of
people online every single day actually
two billion a day are online
so you have to expand your horizon to
what is
and focus on what can be now
somebody type this in right now if you
can i'm going to give you a formula that
has helped me build five multi-million
dollar companies from scratch to
billions in sales a year okay are you
ready here is a magic formula for you
here's the magic formula
traffic times conversion or prospects
times conversion equals revenue
prospects times conversion equals
revenue
traffic times conversion either one
prospect so
the company the person who has the
product or the service
that gets in front of the most amount of
people with the right offer
let me repeat the company the person
that gets in front of the most amount of
people
with the right offer makes the most
amount of money
so here is my question for you right now
are you getting your product or service
in front of people in your local
marketplace
in the your national marketplace or
online right so
if you are not waking up every day
trying to figure out how do i get my
product or my service and what i'm
offering people in front of more people
either through
advertising either through networking
either through joint ventures either
through content either through a variety
of different means
you're going out of business because
there's more than enough people
online or offline i'm giving you an
option it doesn't matter
even if you have a store
a stall a kiosk
even if you're selling your stuff online
it doesn't make a difference you have to
be focusing on how do i get more people
to see what i have to offer and then how
do i create an offer that is so good
that the people who want it and need it
buy from me
if you're not waking up
thinking about that
it's very hard to build your business
absence of knowing we default
to our highest level of training
knowledge and skill so now that you know
you don't know because you've heard me
talk about it now you have awareness do
you know how you will know
is when you apply what i just shared
with you
and you have the visceral experience
that reinforces a neural pattern of just
knowledge with behavior knowledge with
behavior equals experience
reading a book gives you awareness it
doesn't give you knowledge the knowledge
comes from the application and getting
the feedback loops
of all of the sentence all of the senses
integrated into a pattern and if you
reinforce
what you know with what you do you end
up
with results why must you grow your
business why must you can you give me
one answer
why i must figure this out
i'm going to tell you why this is
important from a brain perspective okay
not why i should
why must you
figure this out why must you all right
if you want to build a million dollar
business that has profits of two three
four five hundred thousand dollars if
you want to build a 500 000 business
that has profits of one or two hundred
thousand dollars here's what i want you
to understand when you set a goal to
achieve what you want you're using this
part of the brain right and many of you
know that's the specialty that i love to
talk about is the neuroscience of the
success
but you also have to get the limbic
system the emotional part of your brain
activated when we come up with a why
that is bigger than the stories the
reasons the excuses and pay close
attention
when we come with a why that is bigger
than the stories the reasons and the
excuses that are holding us back now we
will then
master change instead of mastering
disappointment did you get that
you have to come up with a reason why
you must upgrade your knowledge your
skills your beliefs your habits and your
behaviors
or
you will
find it easier to master disappointment
versus mastering change i'm going to
just chill
out here on the beach in malibu and get
a little bit of sunshine when it comes
up it's a little cloudy day was
beautiful yesterday i'll go for some
nice walks along the beach i'll take
i'll show you a little
you know just looking on the beach
oh there i'll take my tripod look at
that
just beautiful beautiful beautiful
that side and
beautiful on that side
whoa
limiting beliefs
if we have constructive positive
empowering beliefs
we move forward and take action but when
we have a limiting belief like i'm not
good enough i'm not smart enough i'm not
worthy i'm not skilled i'm too young i'm
too old i'm too white i'm too black i'm
too asian caucasian i'm this or i'm that
i'm not enough of this i'm not enough of
that
where are our beliefs
right we have two types of beliefs we
have conscious beliefs that we can
declare and then we have subconscious
beliefs as well which ones are the more
powerful of the two
mike edwards says subconscious beliefs
right
mike
says subconscious beliefs were you born
with any beliefs like if you were a
neuroanatomist
okay if you're a neuroanatomist if you
were to look in the brain
where would you find your beliefs the
positive the negative ones the good ones
the challenging ones the constructive
destruct where would you find them
what are they like what are they
right like what are they
aren't those patterns
that have been reinforced based on what
we learned in childhood aren't those
patterns that our parents gave us our
teachers our brothers our sisters our
neighbors
right didn't we
develop our beliefs
through the imprinting years zero to
five or six the modeling years five or
six to you know seven or eight and then
the um the um um
experiential years
right all the way from birth to 25 26
when our brain was pretty plastic and we
developed these beliefs about
what to believe
we weren't born with any they're nothing
more than neural patterns in the brain
now how many of you have heard the word
neuroplasticity
neuroplasticity right what is
neuroplasticity neuroplasticity
is the scientific fact that our brain
is plastic
right what does that mean it's not like
plastic like this brain
it means that we have brain cells
right so the brain cells okay there's a
cell
there's an axon okay or a body then
there's dendrites at the end right and
there's synaptic gaps in between the
brain cells so those brains have
potentiality and let's say we are told
that you're not good enough you're not
smart enough you're not worthy you'll
never amount to much you're too young
you're too old you don't have enough
knowledge you don't have enough skill if
those patterns
are created and those neurons are active
and releasing those neural chemicals
from a receptor or from a ascending
neuron to a receptor neuron and that
happens often enough that neuron
structure or pathway
becomes more solid just like
developing a highway system in a city
and the pathways that are active and
reinforced when we are young
become the default pathways just like
the highways and the roads that you take
every single day to go to the stores you
take now if it's true that our neural
pathways are not fixed but the pathways
that are easy to run across okay or to
fire the signals okay are the ones that
are dominant
is it possible
to let go of the limiting destructive
disempowering beliefs
that somebody else gave us for the most
part or we experienced
is it possible that through
conditioning programming deliberately
choosing our beliefs
and reinforcing new neural pathways we
can
create new neural pathways
right so
if a neural pathway can be created and
neural pathways can be deactivated
then why not deliberately unconsciously
evolve yourself if your self-image
is
not in coherence
with the goal that you want to achieve
you'll sabotage your success we
discovered that self-esteem if there's a
disconnect between our vision and goals
and self-esteem self-esteem will drag us
down procrastinate sabotage rationalize
those are the causes or the self-esteem
is one of the causes that holds us back
here's what i learned many many years
ago and i'm going to leave you with this
one of my mentors who is a billionaire
said john i don't want you to get
stronger at your weaknesses
i want you to get stronger at your
strengths
i want you to manage your weaknesses
hmm
manage my weaknesses i said to him how
do i manage my weaknesses he says you
practice radical honesty about what
you're strong in
create a plan to get better and you are
radically honest what you're not good at
and you find people to help you
who are good at that now here is what
i'm going to leave you with
he said to me
hire people
who play
at things you have to work at
hire people who play
at things
you have to work at and i can fill in
the blank like i did before say you can
hire bar to defer payment or partner
with people who play at the things that
you have to work at
all right so
if you're not good at certain parts of
business that's okay you need to admit
you're not good at it but your job as
the ceo of your business is to figure
out how am i going to get that done
by asking better questions you get
better answers but by saying i'm not
good at that i don't know how to do that
i don't like that you're reinforcing
your patterns in your brain
you're reinforcing patterns in your
brain that are going to make you worse
at it
so instead of putting yourself down lift
yourself up instead of coming up with
stories and reasons and excuses why you
can't focus your brain on how you will
because you must you gotta clear through
the noise of negativity out there stay
positive because
people are buying people are buying
people are buying right now
right now
and that means that there is more
business available to you but you have
to manage your mindset upgrade your
skill set and then make sure that you're
taking the right actions in the right
order
at the right time fear but what is fear
is fear something that you should fear
no
i want you to imagine that you're
driving down the street in your car
and a light pops up on the dashboard
a light pops up
um
have you ever taken a hammer and hit the
light because you don't like the light
of course not that would be silly right
what if the light on the dashboard was
just a signal maybe you're low on tire
air
air pressure maybe you're missing air or
water in your windshield wiper maybe the
back trunk door is open
isn't
the signal in your car
just for you to be aware that maybe
something is wrong or something needs
attention
is it possible
that if we stop thinking of fear as the
enemy fear is one of your biggest
friends why
well when you understand how did this
organism
okay develop and how
does it keep us alive
it pays attention to things okay in your
external world triggers from your
external word that could cause your
death
or destruction it causes you to do what
when there is a potential
that threat
predator or threat at the door
it lights up the fear signal sends
cortisol epinephrine or norepinephrine
into your bloodstream so you either know
how to fight it you run away or you
freeze hoping that the predator will go
away so when your brain
every brain
gets this signal
that there is a threat
at the door
it sends a signal
in the form of a neurochemical that you
feel
now if somebody
feels this threat in their body but they
don't know how to manage the emotion we
call fear
let's say there's a fear that you have a
failure and what it might mean to your
family what what about a fear of losing
money and not having enough to pay the
rent the mortgage or for retirement what
if there's a fear of trying something
and then it not working out and you're
embarrassed or ashamed or ridiculed or
rejected or judged oh my god if you
judge me then you're gonna reinforce my
low self-esteem of myself and then all
this [ __ ] then who am i
you understand what's happening in the
circuits i'm just describing
so when our brain has
this fierce circuit activated do you
think the fear circuit causes you to go
oh hey let's take action anyway
or do you think it goes hi alert hi
alert hi alert be aware what's going on
what if you fail what if you succeed
with succeed and fail
whenever that circuit is triggered
motivational circuit shuts down whenever
that circuit is activated your thinking
circuit shuts down all the blood flow
goes into a part of your brain to help
you do what possibly run away protect
yourself
it's a protection mechanism but here is
what i want you to remember
this automatic trigger and circuit
has been evolving for millions of years
but your specific experiences since you
were born in the modeling experiential
and the
um and the imprinting years caused you
to have
beliefs
about things some empower you some
disempower let me give you an example
okay let me give you an example
when i say the word
or let me give you a different uh same
example with just a little different
story
if i say to you that i'd like to take a
big snake about five feet long and let
it slither across your arm and around
your neck and it's a python
how many of you go oh wow that would be
great
versus how many of you are going oh my
god let me run away get get it off of me
just just think of a snake slithering on
you and curling itself around your neck
how many of you are like run
versus oh my god that would be great can
you take a picture of me with it so i
put on social media
so
is it really the snake
that is the threat
or is it
your concept
in your brain the meaning that you have
associated with a snake that is
activating for some of you the reward
center
and for others the fear center same
stake stain stimuli there isn't even a
snake here i just add you think about it
right and it triggered that fear circuit
for some reward circuit for others so
it's never about the thing so when we
have fear
of being embarrassed ashamed ridiculed
judged uh fear of disappointing
ourselves fear of failing if you're
succeeding there's 50 different types of
fears
we automatically trigger
the circuit
that does what stops our action taking
what if
you said okay i want to make let's just
say a hundred thousand dollars a year or
a million it doesn't make a difference
and i asked you
what do you need to believe about
yourself to achieve this so i need to
believe i'm smart enough good write down
i am smart enough what else do you need
to believe i need to believe that i am
worthy i need to believe that i deserve
this i need to believe that it's
possible i need to leave you write down
five or six or seven beliefs are just
words on a sheet of paper
now let me stop for just a moment i'm
gonna tell a story and come back to this
i want you to imagine
that somebody tapped you
on the shoulder sometime today and say
hey
um i work with steven spielberg and tom
hanks in hollywood and we have this new
script okay that if you get really good
at this script where you could read it
in front of a camera without the script
we'll pay you 10 million bucks
now i want you to imagine you've never
seen the script you don't know how to
act but they said to you we're going to
give you an acting coach we're going to
give you everything you need to memorize
the script we're going to do everything
you need to act it perfectly what would
you do
to take that script that's on a piece of
paper that you've never seen before what
would you do to take that script
to make it yours for you to own it and
the answer is you probably read it like
what once
uh would you read it maybe a hundred
times 200 times 500 times do you think
you might
role play with somebody while you're
holding the script in your hand do you
think you might research the role do you
think you might take a camera and
practice it and you think that if you
practice it one time 50 times 100 times
500 times you can finally put the script
down and you can get in front of the
camera and go boom here is the script do
you think you could do that well guess
what a script that's on a piece of paper
that you don't believe with practice you
start to believe so what happens if you
take a belief
system and you start to imprint it into
your subconscious mind initially through
conscious repetition but there are ways
to access the subconscious mind that we
know today that are faster and easier
than just doing it consciously and so
you take a vision of you achieving your
goals and dreams you take the beliefs
you need you learn how to manage your
emotions a little bit better and then
you develop the habits which again are
nothing more than neural patterns in the
brain have been reinforced and when you
learn how to deactivate the destructive
ones and activate constructive ones
through space repetition and
reinforcement now you are resetting your
default way of being
so a belief is nothing more than a
reinforced pattern that if you learn how
to deactivate it and create a new one
it's like a software upgrade for your
brain until you learn how to master your
mindset
by recognizing what's holding you back
the real reasons that you're not taking
the actions that you need to take
and learn how to reframe them in the
right part of your brain so you can
override the messaging signal from the
amygdala the fear center the emotional
center of the brain to the
part of the brain that's responsible for
taking action
you're never going to achieve your goals
so whether you have doubts or fears or
anxieties fear success for your failure
if you're losing your job fear losing
your home fear losing your money
you have to understand that just like
a car
has a light that pops up on the
dashboard when something's wrong in the
engine
you have an emotion that is your signal
to let you know whether you're feeling
good or not whether you're comfortable
or not whether you have certainty or not
whether you have confidence or not
and if you're lacking the confidence and
the certainty it's going to cause doubt
if you're going to have doubt it may
cause anxiety and as soon as that sets
into the brain in a nanosecond
your ability to take action
is like having one foot on the gas and
one foot on the brake
there's gonna be a lot of movement going
on the tires but you're really not going
to get anywhere
so the first thing i want you to do
is write down
what's really holding you back
why aren't you really get clear get deep
why aren't you really taking action
towards any of your goals health goals
financial goals business goals whatever
goals you have
write that down
and ask yourself
is this real is this imagined is it a
probability or is it a possibility what
you'll find
for the most part is the negative
consequence
is a possibility and as soon as you buy
into that possibility you're going to do
everything possible to run away to fight
freeze or fight that feeling
but when you learn how to switch your
brain from recognizing what's holding
you back
to reframing the possibility to
do it from the probability to just a
normal possibility
you start to activate
different parts of your brain that
starts showing you the solutions
to how to overcome the fear how to
overcome the risk how to overcome the
possible negative consequence and then
what happens is the amygdala the part of
your brain that's responsible to protect
you and keep you safe the firing
threshold of that signal gets lowered
the message to the motor cortex doesn't
get sent so you start to take action
and third what is happening
is that your left prefrontal cortex the
ceo the genius part of your brain
starts to think about ways that you can
actually take action and do it faster
and easier and better it starts to
change what you see start to change your
vibration and now you start to have
a lot more control
over not just having goals and having
strategies and plans but getting
yourself to take action crazy time in
the world right now
so much
uncertainty
unpredictability
chaos confusion
lots of stuff that's happening right now
that
none of us have ever been a part of
stuff like it yeah world war ii
some recessions sure
but never anything like this with so
many
different competing
threats
so many different competing
things to be thinking about that
affect your life every day your business
your career your family your health
lots of stuff going on and the question
i want you to be in
what are you going to do to make sure
that your health is better than it is
right now that your finances are better
than they are right now that your
relationship is better than it is right
now that your career or business is
better than it is right now
and the reason i want you to focus on
making it better is because
where your attention goes energy flows
let me repeat where your attention goes
energy flows so if your attention is on
oh my god what's happening what am i
going to do about it what if this
happens what if that happens what if i
can't what if i don't what if i
listen what if you do
what if you focus your energy and
attention on how to make everything
better right now what will you do
differently today tomorrow this week
next week what will you do differently
is what's going to make the difference
more of the same equals
more of the same so i want you to
recalibrate your focus recalibrate your
attention recalibrate your intention
and then i want you to start some
planning
behavior equals results and it's the
behavior you take or the behavior you
don't take either one is a behavior
you have more control than you think you
do
you have more abilities than you think
you do
and i know that with focused attention
and follow-through right follow-through
you can have
a great next 90 days the question is are
you committed to a great next 90 days i
am looking for me my team
my private clients you to finish the
year off strong
and to start next year fast
and strong and that's going to take some
thinking some planning and execution the
discipline to follow through to
completion
are you in for the challenge
i'm here to support you my team's here
to support you
the tribe is here to support you
together we're going to lift each other
as we climb
towards having an amazing
next
few months it dawned on me that
sometimes we don't have the right frames
when we're doing something
and we don't
give things the right meanings
and let me explain what i mean to you by
that
when we
start something new
i think sometimes we forget
that anything that is new
to our brain
may be exciting and uh may release
dopamine the neurochemical that uh you
know the reward neurochemical
and uh we feel good because we've taken
on this new endeavor whether it's a new
language whether it's retraining our
brain
whether it's um starting to exercise or
eating better or committing to doing
something that's of benefit to us or
even stopping something
now the very nature of how our brain
works
is that patterns that have been repeated
over you know months and years are the
dominant patterns in our brain
and therefore it's easier for our brain
to activate and follow through to
completion on those patterns it's like
having a you know highway system that's
been built it's easy for the cars to go
faster on the highway system well the
same thing is true with our brain and
the neural networks and pathways
so the
pathways are the easiest for the
chemicals to travel across
and release the
neural chemicals you know that make us
feel good or make us feel fearful or
make us feel apprehensive or doubtful
etcetera
are the ones that are the easiest for
our brain to activate and follow through
on okay part one
so that means that a new pattern
meaning stopping something or starting
something requires
a little bit more of the brain's energy
and the brain wants to conserve energy
so what is
our brain naturally going to do
and the answer is
it's going to resist why because it
wants to preserve
the energy that may be required in case
there's a saber-tooth tiger that comes
around from you know the woods to try
and kill you so we're in this energy
conservation
mindset without even knowing it
our biology is geared towards doing
things that are easy for us not things
that require
energy right glucose
so why am i sharing this with you well
as you're you know on your journey
of brain training upgrading your
knowledge and skills taking actions
probably different actions that you are
taking to achieve the results that you
want more and better results from
of
it requires you
accessing higher cortical functions
and a higher level of awareness
especially pay close attention
especially
when you feel resistance now
i came out here and i still have my
workout gloves on because as i was doing
uh some ab work as i was doing you know
some um bench press and flies for my
chest
one of the things that dawned on me is
most people
do things that they're comfortable doing
but
in order to get stronger from a
cardiovascular perspective you have to
challenge yourself
mix up your routines you've got to go a
little bit longer a little bit harder um
uh you know on the days that you want to
expand your capabilities
so
in the world of uh you know doing
weights for strength training or
building muscle there are certain
techniques
to use in certain strategies used
including rest right
muscles build
built
in the rest phase so let me explain what
i'm talking about i think you know where
i'm going with this
i let's say do a bench press or a fly or
i walk up a hill
the place where it's the hardest where
there's resistance
where i want to quit and stop and i'm
breathing heavier i just can't do
another rep
that's the point of the growth
and the more you practice at that place
right the resistance the point i want to
quit i can't do it anymore
that is how you expand your capacity
resistance happens
when
you're at the edges of your capacity now
it could be mental edges
emotional edges
physical edges financial edges and how
does it show up it shows up as stress
right stress so
stress happens when your current
capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current
capacity
exceeds
the demand
your current capacity exceeds the demand
so how do you increase demand i'm sorry
how do you increase capacity well you
feel the edges and go one more you feel
the tension and keep doing it you feel
the desire to quit but then you do as
much as you can and as you do as much as
you can
you get mentally stronger physically
stronger emotionally stronger
so
when i feel like let's say quitting i
just say just a little bit more
when i don't feel like it i say i know
but just do a little bit why because i
want to override my natural and your
natural propensity to want to quit to
want to stop it's natural
but i don't want to be natural i want to
be supernatural i don't want to be
ordinary i want to be extraordinary and
that's that little extra does that make
sense so as you're training your brain
as you have videos to watch to upgrade
your knowledge and skills as you have
events to attend you know to to connect
to to listen to learn to expand
if you catch yourself thinking or
feeling i don't feel like it i'm too
tired not today tomorrow
that's the language okay that the brain
uses the rationalization the rational
lies
that your brain my brain everybody's
brain uses to keep you in your comfort
zone well guess what everything you want
financially in your relationship
health-wise is just outside your comfort
zone if you keep challenging and
expanding your mental emotional physical
spiritual financial comfort zones
you expand as a human being and you
start fulfilling more of your potential
than standing on the edge of it hoping
and praying and wishing that you can
have greater better results in our brain
we're always balancing out whether to
move forward or to retreat into safety
and so the reason we don't take action
and we procrastinate in sabotage
in a lot of cases because our brain is
processed that taking action is riskier
than remaining the same and here is
something that your brain's always doing
it is
analyzing
okay your stories reasons excuses and
potential
uncomfortable feelings or outcomes
against the behavior that needs to be
taken and so it's easier for us to
remain the same than it is for us to
overcome our fears
it's easier for us to remain the same
versus overcome our limiting beliefs
it's easier for us to remain the same
versus challenging our self-esteem
self-worth stories and excuses so when
you have a big must why you must achieve
that goal
and when that must is bigger
than your self-image your stories your
excuses or your fears
that is when you will take action so you
have to create leverage with your big
must
or musts
and so when you have your five big musts
and you compare them against remaining
the same or the fear of failure or the
fear of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed or judged when your must is
bigger than those things that's when
you'll take inspired action and you
already know this if you followed my
work that we do more to avoid pain
or discomfort whether it's real or
imagined we do more to avoid pain or
discomfort really imagined than we will
do to gain pleasure so we have to create
leverage
in our mind a lot of people ask me what
happens in our brain when we have a
traumatic
experience or a negative experience or
an experience where we're embarrassed or
ashamed or ridiculed or judged whether
it's as a kid or as an adult
well as you know the neurons that fire
together wire together right
and what happens when we have a negative
experience or a painful one
is that those neurons that wire together
create this
memory in the amygdala the emotional
reactive center of the brain
and that amygdala is tied deeply towards
survival and avoidance of any pain or
discomfort so it is one of the most
refined parts of our brain the amygdala
the emotional response center of our
brain
when we have a pleasurable experience
that gets more wired in the hippocampus
part of our brain
and so
why do we avoid things that might cause
us pain or discomfort
uh well that's just the way we're wired
and we will move further and further and
further away from something and faster
away from something
then we will move towards gaining the
pleasure it's just the way the circuitry
is working
and so what we need to understand is
the circuits work perfectly
and that means that your brain works
perfectly now the key is to become
better at recognizing
and
managing emotions
and for that we have the for our process
right recognize thoughts emotions
feeling sensations behaviors
when you have an emotion
or a feeling that doesn't feel
comfortable
breathe six deep breaths you know that
inner size take six calm the circuits
well you inner size breathe your way
through it
and then to do inner size number two
which is ayah awareness of
the thoughts feelings emotions
sensations and behaviors
and it's in the awareness that you have
choice and it's in the choice that you
have freedom
when you make the choices to take action
anyway and to be aware of the old
pattern
and to disempower it disengage it
don't reinforce it right if we keep
reinforcing these disempowering patterns
then guess what we do
we keep doing them over and over and
over
and over again so recognize
reframe them by giving them a different
meaning release them through breathing
and retrain your brain by taking
inspired action anyway
so
there's nothing wrong with your emotions
nothing wrong with your feelings
some are empowering you some are
disempowering some are positive some are
negative some are constructive some are
destructive
i have emotions i'm not my emotions i
have feelings i'm not my feelings
i have a brain i am not my brain
i can use my brain better
awareness is what's going to give you
choice and choice is what ultimately
will give you the freedom that you want
have you ever considered that
procrastination
is a behavior
when you
choose either
by your own decision making or because
of automatic decision-making patterns
not to take action on
either a goal that you have
a business achievement you want to
create
writing a book or anything that you have
the goal or vision or dream to achieve
when you don't take action and you're
procrastinating that in itself is a
behavior right
in essence it's a form of self-sabotage
where you have a vision you have a goal
you want it
but you still don't take action on it or
you take a little bit of action and then
you stop
the question is why why do we
procrastinate why do we self-sabotage
and the answer must be something in your
brain right and the obvious solution is
to find out well what's triggering
procrastination what's triggering the
self-sabotaging
behavior and usually it's going to come
down to one of three things all right
number one is fear fear of not doing it
well enough fear of being judged fear of
being embarrassed the work that you've
done fear of failing
those are you know just a few of the
fears that may be holding you back the
other thing that it could be is that the
achievement of the goal that you have
the thing that you want
may be just outside of your hidden
self-image
and so when your hidden self image
sees that the thing that you want is
bigger than your current comfort zone
your current comfort um is all based on
your hidden self image then you're going
to procrastinate and self sabotage these
are just automatic circuits and
mechanisms in your brain
and then there's you know the third one
that everybody knows about that's
limiting beliefs
is we could have limited beliefs that
you know we're not smart enough we don't
have the skill we're too young or too
old and so any one of those three things
limiting beliefs fears or self-image
challenges that are hidden in the
subconscious mind
is really what you have to go to work at
to change those when you change those
you're in essence removing the obstacles
that are impeding you from actually
taking inspired action there's another
part of your brain
called the striatum
which is connected or part of
a network
known as your hippocampus
a part of your brain called your
hippocampus where your memories and
habits are interrelated between
hippocampus and striatum now
habits are created
in our brain to conserve energy to not
have us think consciously about what we
need to do so here is my question for
you
what is one habit
that by starting this habit makes the
achievement of that goal
predictable
so is it waking up early and upgrading
your skills by 20 minutes is it going to
bed early is it
being in a coaching program or a
mastermind program we have
accountability is it you know doing 15
minutes of exercise a day is it stopping
to eat certain foods is it you know
having a meeting with your significant
other every week to talk about your
goals and how you're feeling what is a
keystone habit i call it
that's going to move you forward that
over the next 100 days not 20 days 10
days 5 days or 33 days 100 days when you
develop that habit that habit then
develops you
meaning a positive constructive
empowering habit that you focus on for a
short period of time every day
that moves you towards that goal there
are behaviors that when you apply them
every single day like a ritual a habit
they are the building blocks to achieve
any goal and since we know that every
single goal that you want to achieve in
health wealth relationships career
business finances fun experiences
charities
all the how to exist but you have to
have the habits to not just create a
pattern that is short term but a pattern
that is long term now initially you have
to use conscious effort energy and
attention to create a habit but you can
deliberately and consciously choose
habits versus being a victim of the
habits that you are repeating over and
over and over again when you figure out
some of the math and then you ask
yourself okay
how am i gonna get my product or service
knowledge or skills that i'm selling
whatever it is that you're selling how
do i get that
in front of the right prospects i'm
going to keep coming back and forth
either online or offline
online or offline how much do you think
achieving business success is an inner
game
thing
do you think that that it's a
combination of winning the inner game
and also winning the outer game of what
you need to do you and i own the most
powerful biocomputer in the whole
universe
that can help us achieve our goals
faster and easier than ever before but
if we're focusing on why we can't
if we're not focusing on knowing the
numbers if we're not focusing on
understanding how do we take
our product or service and create
marketing
and a selling process to get it in front
of people
then we're missing
the syntax the process to achieve the
success that we want if you were out of
shape physical shape okay how would you
get back in shape like what would you do
think let's be realistic logical if
you're out of shape you've been out of
shape you're overweight uh you're not as
healthy as you can be
right
what would you do if you made a
commitment to be in shape
okay right if you were committed to
being in shape let's talk about
physically right now
what would you do to break the pattern
the software
so um
somebody says you could diet you can
exercise
uh you can sleep um well right get six
to eight hours of sleep so you reduce
your cortisol levels and reduce your
leptin levels so diet go on go to the
gym visualize motivate willie says start
gradually um right you can
you can create a vision board and see
yourself right in shape
right you can start with small steps you
can get an accountability partner you
can join a gym you can hire a coach uh
you can ask a
family member or friend if she or he
would like to you know start small so
you can develop the habits magic charts
321 right so what our habits habits are
automatic combinations of thoughts
emotions uh feelings sensations and
behaviors that are all automatic to do
without thought but to get to a habit
right to get to a habit we have to start
all right with how we think right
we have to continue with how do we feel
motivated or unmotivated well how do we
get motivated how do we stay motivated
then we need to know what are the
behaviors that we want to take so we
want to work
on an inner game
and an outer game so all of my students
for example all my private clients
whether i'm working with a ceo or an
athlete or a home maker doesn't matter i
ask them to commit to 100 days
okay to develop a new
pattern
that they can reinforce so do you think
it's reasonable let me ask you a
question
do you think it's reasonable
to say to yourself
that i'm gonna commit to 100 days to
give myself the best chances of a solid
foundation that i could build upon so
instead of thinking that i'm going to
change a result or change a habit that
i've had for 10 20 30 years in a weekend
or in a week or two or three that's just
unrealistic do you think that if we just
change the expectation
and we said okay
i'm gonna do it fast but i'm not going
to do it so fast that i don't sustain
sustain the thinking the emotions and
the behaviors so here's what i want to
ask you right if you're committed to an
outcome that you don't just want to
achieve and then stop
right
then why not commit to a process that
you can continue and people will do
things
for either a reason
a season or a lifetime a reason a season
or a lifetime here's what we know okay
let's say
you've been earning a certain amount of
income for the last you know 10 years
all right within range uh and you wanna
maybe double or triple your income
isn't it worth it
to be disciplined
to
sustainable change versus you know rapid
change that goes away
if we are creatures of habit
then why not get really good at develop
empowering constructive positive habits
why not get good at upgrading our own
mental and emotional behavioral software
so that once we do it we can just
sustain it because we set a new
expectation for ourselves
there's too many people
okay
out there teaching you know fast food
thinking you know lose all the weight in
seven days well you're gonna gain it all
back because most of the weight you lose
is water
right uh let's see how much money i can
make this weekend well that's great but
you're not going to sustain it because
the habit is not there
this is why
people who win the lottery lose it
within three years and people who lose
money that they've made it
gain it back within three years because
they have the neural pattern
of the behavior when i analyze
businesses
whether they're startups or doing a
hundred million dollars in revenue
doesn't make a difference
usually there's something in one of
those three or all of those three that
is missing
and so when we start to focus on
getting the inner game right plus what
you need to do and then you do it
the results are pretty easy
so here's what i want you to ask
yourself
are there people out there
all right that could buy your product or
service but you don't know how to reach
them
right is it possible that there's people
out there that need what you have your
product your service your knowledge your
skills whatever it is that you're
selling
offering to the marketplace is it
possible
that you just don't know how to reach
them
so that means that it's a skill set
issue right
now
in 2021
we know how to do those things they're
like i said earlier where i started
right the fact that there are two
billion people a day
online
means that there's more than enough
people to get in front of listen in the
old in the old days right um when we
didn't have the internet we had to
advertise you know in the newspapers
postcards
magazines radio television or set up a
store in a shopping center
but now just about every single business
okay
is online offering information content
to develop a relationship and rapport
with prospects and they're taking them
through a process yellow pages that's
right thank you
muse debbie debbie muse
right so yellow pages
so here's the thing one of the formulas
that you must figure out is where i
started before traffic times conversion
equals revenue the added version to that
is traffic times conversion plus
repeat business and referrals equals
exponential revenue
traffic times conversion equals revenue
now traffic times conversion plus
referrals and repeat business equals
exponential revenue and so one of the
things that you need to be thinking
about okay and if this is the only thing
that you leave today i'm gonna give you
a couple things number one is i need to
adapt i need to adapt to the market and
use all the tools available to me but
not use every one of them
i want you to ask yourself the question
i posed earlier is what has to happen in
order for me to just double or triple
the leads that i get
leads
the the prospects coming to see you
online or offline if you just focused on
that question
what has to happen in order for me to
double or triple my prospects or leads
and i'm not sure who said that you
picked up the answer virginia yeah this
is
this is my new york times best-selling
book the answer uh if anybody's read it
uh it is a new york times bestseller for
many many many years now one of the best
books on the inner game and outer game
of business
uh i put that back
over there
on my on my thing um but i didn't come
here to to sell you on my on my book i
want to give you information if anybody
wants to get the book on amazon for 15
or less
it'll blow your mind and the lux coast
you're reading it now awesome so
when we understand there's already a
process in place
and we discover
how do we take our product or service
and create the marketing how many of you
are you good in marketing
are you good in marketing meaning i'm
not talking about branding
i'm talking about getting your product
or service with the right message
in front of the ideal client
if you're not good at marketing okay i
want you to let me know are you good at
marketing yes or no so you're not good
at marketing
think about this if you're a business
owner
there's a couple of different hats that
you have to make sure are being taken
care of right in business if you're a
business owner with a product or service
you have to have somebody who's doing
the marketing right which is developing
your brand creating your messaging for
how you're going to promote your product
or service to people who don't know you
you have to learn how to sell and
selling is doing something for somebody
not to somebody
you need to learn how to manage
you need to learn how to either develop
products you need to learn some of the
technology needs that you have there's a
lot of different hats
that you have to wear
or you have to make sure that somebody
in your company
is wearing that hat right
and so
imagine if you're
needs surgery but you're not a good
surgeon what would you do
you'd have to find how do i get somebody
who could do the surgery so for those of
you who are not good at marketing or
sales which is the oxygen required for
any business regardless of how good your
product or service are
the question you want to be asking
yourself is this who can i hire to help
me
or who can i barter with to help me who
can i partner with to help me
do my marketing and sales if you're not
good at that so hire
partner barter
or
defer payment to get it done because
without
marketing and selling
you really don't have a business and
those are skills that either you have
that you need to develop or you don't
have you're not good at you don't want
it but you still need to figure out as a
business owner how am i going to get it
done your job as a business owner is not
to do everything
but to make sure that everything that is
oxygen and is required gets done after i
you know got into real estate and i
traveled the world i um i ended up
buying the franchising rights for re max
for the state of indiana
and i was 26 years old
and i bought the franchising rights for
india and i moved to indiana and i
remember being interviewed for the
indianapolis business journal and the
guy said what are your goals here in
indiana
26 years old i was wearing you know i
remember a brown pinstripe suit uh i had
glasses on even though i didn't need
glasses i just want to look older
and i said we'll do a billion dollars in
sales in indiana
and the gentleman said to me says are
you um certain of that i said well
that's my goal
he says well their two largest companies
have been here for a hundred years don't
do a hundred
million dollars a hundred or a billion
dollars combined
and my cocky young self i said well not
first
he's not right here yeah just three
weeks later the in-nap is business
journal and i have it at home it says
sets one billion dollar goal wow um may
1992 we hit a billion dollars in sales
five years later wow and we were stuck
one of the things that i was taught
playing sports was repetition is the
mother of skill repetition is the mother
of skill which is another lesson that i
learned at a very young age why
does any piano coach guitar coach
coach for sports have their students
repeat drills over and over and over and
over again whether it's layups or free
throws or playing you know certain
chords on the guitar or on the piano why
is repetition so important
the answer is because
when you repeat a pattern over and over
and over again whether it's a language
pattern an emotional pattern or a
behavioral pattern when you repeat it
over and over and over and over again 20
times 50 times 100 times 200 times 500
times a thousand times you actually are
creating patterns in the brain that
initially
go from being conscious patterns
patterns that require effort and
intention and attention your conscious
mind
to patterns that become non-conscious
that require
less energy
and less attention because it's been
repeated so many times it becomes second
nature you may have heard me say before
awareness
is what gives you choice
and choice is what can give you freedom
right so awareness of what
awareness of your thoughts what are you
thinking about most of the time
is it constructive is it destructive
are your thoughts empowering you or
disempowering you are they positive or
negative now what if you were able to
practice being aware
without judgment
blame
shame
guilt or justification let me repeat no
judgment blame shame guilt or
justification now
why do you want to get good at awareness
the answer is because awareness
is what allows you to see patterns
and once you see a pattern
then you can change the pattern in all
of the research that's been done around
addictions for example whether it's
addictions to nicotine sex
porn
sugar
overeating under eating over exercising
not exercising
one of the key things that all the
scientists agree on now
is the very act of observing and
learning your patterns allows you to
determine whether you want that pattern
to continue
and to also ask why is this pattern here
what's causing the things that i do
what is causing these thoughts what's
triggering these emotions
what's behind the anger what's behind
the fear what's behind
the feeling like i'm not good enough
worthy enough etc
and in that quiet observation without
judgment blame shame guilt or
justification
we can start to make modifications
and then we use our higher cortical
functions
of intention
attention
and action
to change so awareness intention
attention
and action
that is the
simple version of how we change how we
become more how we
surrender allow accept
all of us have patterns some serve us
well some don't that's just a natural
fact most of it's because of childhood
experiences the meaning that we gave
things the
skills that we gained or didn't gain
so what
the key is start right now get better
today get better tomorrow get better the
next day
over the course of
three months six months 12 months
you have more mental control you have
more emotional control you have more
direction on your behaviors
and when you learn what you should be
doing
holy mackerel you could be healthier
happier wealthier and more first and
foremost you know i like to deal with
reality
of what is going on and what is the
truth first and foremost now let me ask
you a question
would you agree
that
times of uncertainty
times maybe a fear for some people times
of stress for some people
is also a time for us to learn how to
adapt
isn't adaptation one of the greatest
skills okay
that we as humans can learn and many
years ago when i was in the galapagos
islands
i bought a hat and if you have ever been
to the galapagos you'll know that it's
like going back five million years and
there's a saying there and i got this
hat says adapt or die why because the
survival of the fittest
okay the whole idea of survival of the
fittest is based on darwin's work and we
actually retraced his trail with uh with
the beagle when he was writing about the
survival of the fittest and learning
about adaptation is the animals that
learned to adapt were the ones that
survived the ones that got to survive
obviously multiplied so here is my
question for you okay
we are sometimes the most advanced
species on earth uh most intelligent and
i'm gonna say sometimes right what are
you doing to adapt right now
what are you doing to adapt right now
what are you doing to adapt mentally
what are you doing to adapt emotionally
what are you doing to adapt physically
what are you doing to adapt spiritually
what are you doing to adapt
financially right those are the five
places of adaptation right so
spiritually mostly mentally physically
financially so what are you doing okay
to adapt
right what are you doing to adapt
when there are things happening in our
environment
whose responsibility is it to adapt
right so let me share something with you
if it's true that
adaptation is a skill
right if it's true that you know as a
human species we have the ability to
adapt let me give you a couple of things
that may help okay and i like that
praying yeah um share with me you know
what you're doing diversion i guess you
didn't like my comments because you're
still here right so share with me how do
you manage let's start with number one
how do you manage your mindset
to go from being reactive
to being responsive is that something
that every one of us can do
when we're reacting
it's usually without any thought
right it's usually without any thought
when we're responding it's usually
because of thought
right and i don't mean just thoughts i
mean thinking so
the way i like to do it is say here's
what's happening whether it's you know
interest rates uh the market crashing
covet monkey parks uh the texas shooting
which please you know let's say some
prayers to all of the families all of
the families
you know that are going through this
nightmare right now
but what can
we do what you and i can do
to respond instead of react
right so naturally depending on the
situation we may react in anger
um and that's that's a part of our fight
flight response right we're gonna act
out of anger and blame and shame and
guilt um that's right but we may act in
a state of fear right fear is a
protective state since the number one
priority of our brain
is to avoid any uh pain or discomfort
but also
to
make sure that anything that is
happening around us
right um is
managed for survival and safety survival
and safety every one of us is 100
self-disciplined already to our current
thought patterns emotional patterns and
behavioral patterns which obviously are
responsible for our results so
my question for you today is this
do you have the right disciplines
do you have the right disciplines to set
goals create plans and achieve them do
you have the right disciplines to prime
your brain
with your vision your goals and your
plans for the day every day do you have
the right discipline to review
your day at the end of the day to see
what did you do well what could be
tweaked so that tomorrow is even better
do you take time on sunday nights for
maybe 30 or 40 minutes to plan your week
so that you're not reacting to stuff but
you're planned you're organized you're
in action that's deliberate versus
reactive that's another discipline
do you take time every month to review
your month do you take time every
quarter to review your quarter do you
take time at the end of each year to
review the whole year and then to plan
your vision for the next year your goals
for the next year now
these little disciplines
are what i call keystone disciplines or
keystone behaviors and habits that set
you up for success and so
i like to consistently ask myself
do i have the right keystone habits the
the big things you know that swing the
little hinges that swing the big doors
so a couple things i can tell you that
really work for me
is taking the time to think to plan
to
review my results and in
a state of no blaming myself no shaming
myself no feeling guilty no justifying
no wishing i wish it was different or
better or this or that just in a pure
state of awareness
i tweak and adjust and tweak and adjust
and tweak and adjust and tweak and
adjust
and here's what happens what you'll
discover is you're gonna be on course a
lot of the time
you're gonna be off course some of the
time
but when you take the time to recognize
if your thoughts are aligned with your
vision and your goals are your emotions
your your things that cause you to take
action and not align with your vision
and goals are the behaviors that you're
taking aligned with achieving those
goals now
when you're in a constant state
of review tweak adjust behave review
tweak adjust behave
that is a
self-disciplined action and habit
that will lead you to achieve every one
of your health wealth relationships
career business charitable
every goal you have
the how to achieve the goal
is the easiest part getting yourself to
take the inspired action because you
have a big reason why you must
is really what you need to work on
because we all are going to have
challenges we're gonna have failures
we're gonna have days we feel like on
top of the world and other days we feel
like oh man i just don't even feel like
getting out of bed that's okay that's
normal that's called being human
but if you have the self-discipline to
get up and do a little bit to get up and
adjust and tweak
then you win the game more than you lose
the game uh think about
athletics for just a moment
to make it into the hall of fame for
exactly for example in baseball
you will not hit
three out of ten balls
you will not hit him you will not get on
base that means you're failing so to
speak seven out of ten times but to make
it to the hall of fame the best of the
best all you need to do is
hit get on base three times so a lot of
people have a misunderstanding of
success and that is that you succeed
every single minute every single hour
every single day and that's not just not
true
right the most successful people in the
world are consistently
taking action
making sure that it's the right action
if it's not they adjust so
have the self-discipline
to
not blame shame justify or make yourself
feel guilty have the self discipline to
create the plans take inspired action
manage your thoughts get into the right
state the physiology the feelings that
you need in order to achieve your goals
dreams take inspired action daily and
don't focus on perfection focus on a
little bit of progress every single day
every one of us has got commitments
whether it's commitments to our family
our friends our children our boss our
employees
our parents our siblings we all have so
many commitments
in every area of our lives health wealth
relationships career business fun
experiences charity
and
how are we supposed to
manage all of it
and the answer is very carefully
one of the only ways that i have learned
how to manage the complexities of life
is to compartmentalize the different
areas of life
and to set up a process
of prioritization based on the highest
values and the
doing the things that
have to get done before any of the other
things
now the reason i bring this up is uh
harry who i just had
lunch with as i mentioned he was sharing
with me that one of the things that
helped him last year was that i gave him
this framework to be able to
manage some of the complexities that
were happening in his very very uh
successful and busy life
and the
framework i gave him was to take each
area of his life and either create you
know a sheet of paper that he can write
on
a whiteboard that he could write on or
even on your computer and ask yourself
in the area of your whether it's
spiritual health
what is one thing that you can do if
that's important to you
every day or every week to make sure
that you can get that done in the area
of your emotional health and well-being
what's one thing that you want to get
done in the area of your mindset what's
one thing you can get done in the area
of your physical body what's one thing
that you can get done either every day
or every week or every month depending
on
what it is that you want to achieve and
then you do the exact same thing
for your business
there aren't 500 different things that
you and i have to do when we focus on
the one thing
in each area of our life and we get that
one thing done
then we're making progress we're moving
the needle down the field now in some
areas of your life of course there's
going to be two or three things but when
you get it out of your head and on to
something that you can look at you get
rid of the neural overwhelm and the
emotional
anxiety that comes by having so many
things that you're trying to think
through in your brain so most people
i've found
they don't take any time
to plan
their health wealth relationships career
business and they have no order to what
they need to do what they must do
and by when
and so when you structure your
your behaviors
from highest importance
to lowest you'll see that some of the
lowest imp things that need to get done
aren't the most impactful they're not
the ones that move the needle
now it just takes a little bit of time
to sit to sit stop what you're doing
sit
think a little bit
create some lists for health
wealth relationship career
business fun and experiences and charity
there's your seven categories
and then
itemize the stuff that you want to get
done
give yourself
the
gift of discipline give yourself the
gift of structure give yourself the gift
of thinking before you act
and then tweak and adjust on a daily or
weekly basis and i promise you
you will become so much more effective
you'll reduce your stress you'll reduce
your anxiety you'll increase your
productivity
and chances are you're gonna increase
being happier and achieve more of your
goals i was just thinking about
the amount of stress that each one of us
has on a day-to-day week-by-week basis
and i know that we're all focusing on
achieving our goals health goals wealth
goals relationship career business fun
experiences
and one of our
health goals
should also be you know well-being
and so my question for you is do you
have a well-being
plan
now
i have a lot of stress in my life
mostly business related just the amount
of work that i want to get done the
goals i want to achieve
and the company that i want to build and
so i work a lot of hours
even when i'm on vacation like i am
right now
i'm thinking about business i'm thinking
about a lot of different things and
what i can share with you for me that
works for me is i also have a wellness
plan that includes
you know proper eating proper sleep
proper
nutrients in the form of vitamins
minerals etc
i also have a exercise regiment a
meditation regiment a vacation plan as
well now all this may sound like a lot
of planning
and the truth is
when you take the time to think about
how do you get yourself in the best
mental emotional
spiritual and physical
health
so that you can achieve all of the goals
that you have
with all the stress of learning new
things of making mistakes of things not
working out
and the only way to do that is you have
to step back sometimes
and allow yourself to rejuvenate first
so that you can actually think about
the goals you have but also the plans to
achieve them
so
i like to get to my home here in
telluride colorado and ski several times
during the you know winter season and
several times in the summer season i
like to travel a lot
and what i find for me is that it
rejuvenates me at every level of the
game
now you may be thinking well i can't
afford to take the time off and the
truth is you can't afford not to one of
my dear friends dr barnett meltzer once
said
if you don't make time for your health
your illness will make time for you
and so in this world of massive amounts
of social media people pulling for our
attention online and offline in our
families and our own you know gyrations
of what goes on into our heads you have
to figure out what is my wellness plan
so that i could be and feel well
and in the absence of a plan there's
going to be stress and when there's a
lot of stress
then there's no time to rejuvenate
and what i find for myself is when i
allow myself to get too stressed
then the easy things are hard and the
hard things feel nearly impossible
and so this is my
plea to you
to come up with some time where you can
take half a day off just to focus on you
get off of technology get off of tv get
off of radio get off of
social media
and focus on your health and well being
whenever i ski i get these
bursts of
inspiration and that's part of actually
not being focused on work
actually allows your imagination and
creativity to
i guess filter through and i had this
thought
that i want to share with you
around one of the greatest lessons i
learned and i've shared this before
with many of my students in my
exceptional life coaching program
and that is this
you can set your goals
based on your current level of skills
your current level of knowledge
your
you know circumstances conditions
or
you can set your goals based on
what you want to achieve
and then figure out what skills do you
need what knowledge do you need
what help do you need what beliefs do
you need
in order to achieve those goals and in
essence
setting your goals based on current
circumstances
is
a limited way of doing it in my opinion
when i know that you and i have
you know a hundred billion dollar brain
that can go to work to figure out
how to achieve almost anything
and so as we you know get into a new
year
i want you to ask yourself some
questions
are you training your life for what you
love are you living the lifestyle of
your dreams
or is there a dream life you would
really love to live
how healthy would you love to be how
much income would you love to make
how much charity would you love to give
how would your relationships be if they
were just the way you wanted them
and why not start with what you really
really really want and don't allow
yourself
to
you know look at your present
circumstances or what's happening in the
world right now but instead go and
create the circumstances
internally and externally
to achieve your goals and dreams give
that a shot
what i can promise you
is by focusing on what you want
and being creative and using your
spiritual genius using your emotional
management techniques that you can
upgrade
using your
ability to stay focused and more aware
to get this physical body of yours into
action
you'll be able to achieve more of your
goals and dreams and if you set your
goals based on your current
circumstances or conditions
don't settle for less
go for gold
go for being the best version of
yourself and become all that you're
capable of becoming a few years ago i
met a guy by the name of dr david
krueger and he's a psychiatrist and he
and i were talking about
stories that we have everybody has a
story we have a money story we teach
about winning the game we teach about
your money story in the winning game of
money program and how to reprogram your
brain for a stronger money story and we
have a story around our health our
relationships our career our businesses
we have a story about everything
and then we go about living that story
over and over and over again and very
few people think about the fact that we
are repeating
the same patterns in many cases of our
parents or even of our own lives from
the time we are 20 30 40 50 60. well
what if you can go to the future
and you can think about if i could
change my story today that would get me
to the future that i want what would the
story say
and in the book
i've given you some inner sizes and some
exercises to start writing out your
story now you may think what do you mean
write out my story
i learned many years ago to write out
my money story my life story my
relationship story and i've always
started in this fashion i'm so happy and
grateful for the fact that
i am living the life of my dreams and i
am traveling all over the world first
class and i am able to give to the
charities that my wife and i and
children love and i'm able to and i
write down in present tense
everything that i'm doing feeling
experiencing for health wealth
relationships career business finances
fun experiences charity i write down a
page or two pages that is a story
that i want my future to be like
and then
i type it out
because i usually write by hand i type
it out and then i laminate it then i'll
record it
and then i'll listen to it over and over
and over again now you may think
that sounds silly why would you do that
why
because any information that you get in
through the senses through your ears
through your eyes that you touch that
you feel
activates neurons in the brain
when those neurons are activated and
they wire together
if you repeat it often enough
your brain says hey
you're investing a lot of time and
energy on this stuff
let me start to put some automatic
processes to make that story real
and this is where
winning
from the inside out comes to play this
is why using meditation and
visualization and mindfulness and
affirmations and emotional matter
emotional management techniques
and subliminal programming all work if
you can get the information into the
brain and you have spaced repetition
backed with emotion
you are going to develop the neural
patterns that will activate something
called automaticity
all right or automaticity is when these
neurons activate automatically and then
your perspective changes your beliefs
start to change your behavior starts to
change the filters by which you see the
world and the lens by which you see the
world start to match up
with the story one of the first things
we do in our way the game of money
program is we help people program a new
money story so they can then earn the
money they want and live the life of
their dreams i remember
25 years ago when my first son was born
in
may of 1995
i felt this incredible
gift that was being given to me
and something weird happened
i went to the bathroom when my
wife's water broke and i showered and i
scrubbed myself
you know from head to toe with a
brush and the thinking that was going on
in my head at the time was
for the last let's say nine months or so
this unborn child was in my
wife's belly
and
whatever was happening this intelligence
and and you know nature doing its thing
i was about to get this gift and i
remember thinking
and i'm not religious just so you know
thinking that god was giving me this
gift right and
this miracle this just incredible
thing called a baby and i remember
feeling
extremely emotional
my life was about to
change and it certainly did i have been
so so so grateful and blessed and
involved every day in the life of my uh
son keenan who was born 25 years ago and
my son noah who was born 23 years ago
and the purpose of this specific video
i wanna just
focus for just a moment on life
have you really ever given some thought
to what it took what it takes to to give
and sustain life so if we reverse back
you know
your life
for however many years you've been born
to the day you were born and reversed
back around 285 days from when your
mother and father had sex
and the sperm and the egg connected and
the x chromosomes and the y chromosomes
interlocked and multiplied 26 times
until you were born
have you ever considered
the billions of years of evolution to
make that happen the
perfection
of that happening many years ago when i
wrote one of my books
i likened life happening to a printing
press imagine
if you are
standing outside of a printing press you
know a company or a building that that
produces books or newspapers
and imagine that in this printing press
or this printing business there's ink
there's paper there's letters you know
the little letters that you stamp on to
things there's everything that's needed
to make a newspaper or to you know to
print a book
and imagine that this printing
business explodes
and all of a sudden somehow by
miracle it all comes together and then a
book lands
you know on the table right next to you
or on the floor right next to you
the idea of that happening is crazy
right
well
the miracle that you are
is crazy right it's just oh my god what
an incredible miracle you are
that i am that we are
and so today i wanted to just remind you
of
the intelligence
that created you the intelligence that
is within you that you are
so
feeling less than
feeling like you're not good enough
feeling like you're not smart enough
feeling like you're not worthy
enough really
you are a miracle of life you are a
miracle of creation
within you
the hydrogen the oxygen the nitrogen the
carbon and all the other elements the
atoms and the molecules that make you
you
is nature's perfection
yes with all of our flaws that
idiosyncrasies and challenges and and
things we do great and things we don't
that's the miracle of you you are unique
only one of a kind
you're not supposed to be like anybody
else
you're not supposed to feel better than
or worse than less than
anybody else
equal
every day
every minute every hour every month
every year
you are a miracle
why not
act that way
why not feel the miracle that you are
why not be
express love give share understand be
compassionate be empathetic
to another human being
who is a miracle
and take a look all around you
because life is a miracle
albert einstein said you can either live
your life as if everything is a miracle
or nothing is a miracle
well today
i want to let you know
you
are a miracle
i want to separate like behaviors and
emotions so usually when people say they
have they're having a bad day
sure certain things may have gone wrong
or something that they tried to do you
know didn't work out
[Music]
all information and experiences are
processed at the non-conscious brain
first and then it gives rise to
something we call a feeling
so emotions are processed
non-consciously the electrical and
chemical reaction to that is called a
feeling
so when i'm not feeling
the way that i want to feel
i don't focus on the feeling i focus on
the cause the neuroelectrical charge
that's occurred in my brain
and in most cases
it's something that you're doing to
interpret an event that's causing the
neuroelectrical signal
causing the feeling
so in meditation for example why do you
meditate
well obviously it's great for a whole
host of of health reasons whether it's
um it's uh less stress less you know
lower blood pressure
less cortisol release etc but the one
thing meditation does more than anything
else
is it gives you the ability to have a
pause of awareness
so that you
sense
what's happening at the non-conscious
level right
and what's happening outside of you
so when somebody behaves a certain way
it's processed at the non-conscious
level gives rise to your conscious mind
for you to
respond
and so when something happens i like to
be able to check in
so that i don't react and i have the
ability to respond
and if you do that enough
through mindfulness being aware just
being aware of exactly what's going on
then you have fewer and fewer of those
times
so you know
something happened last week i was in a
hotel room and i spilled some water on a
shirt that i needed
for a wedding that we were going to and
my wife was oh [ __ ]
she's going off deep and i was just calm
yeah
and she goes aren't you worried about
this
will it help
right but
no let's just figure out what to do the
accident already happened maxwell maltz
wrote a great book many many years ago
in the probably the 70s
called psycho cybernetics right and
maxwell moss was a surgeon who performed
surgery on people and what he notices
even after plastic surgery that he
performed on people some people didn't
see any change in their faces and it was
visible to everybody else but not to
them because they had a map of what they
thought they look like yes okay so we
all have
a map of reality we have a map of what
we think we look like
and any deviation on the physical level
to that map to that visual
representation we have in our brains
that doesn't match the map your brain
deletes or distorts it
so
when we were working with real estate or
when i worked with business owners in
addition to upgrading knowledge and
skills
if you think about how let's say income
we have set points for how much income
we earn so whether it's 10 000 a year or
20 or 50 or 100 or a million it doesn't
matter we get this set point and then we
behave the way we need to behave and we
feel we need to feel to earn that income
and over a period of time it becomes
part of the brain's default mode network
so we develop set points for everything
and so if the set points in the brain
and there's a psycho-cybernetic
mechanism in the brain a control and
response mechanism
in the brain and it's our brain
why not learn how
to reset the set point
and so now we're looking at what
technologies are available to help help
reset that
what
evidence-based methods are there to set
that or to reset that
and so when we take let's say
visualization right and you start to see
yourself even if the picture is not
clear in your mind of achieving the next
level of your success whether it's
releasing weight and keeping it off
getting into a relationship that you
love and are happy and whether it's to
make two or three or five times more
money and live a certain type of
lifestyle that allows you to do the
things that freedom
with having money allows you to do if
you start in your mind first and you
impress
that through conscious efforts into the
subconscious mind
it then causes thoughts and emotions and
behaviors
so i like to work from the outside in
and from the inside out so use both
i want every advantage
it's interesting so i've heard you now a
few times and and the first few times it
didn't really make my radar but you
always say release weight you never say
lose weight here's something you could
do quickly it's called a reframe so so
let's say you're driving in traffic and
let's say somebody cuts you off and
you've been sitting at the same spot for
you know 20 minutes like i did this
morning
and somebody you know you're maybe
looking down at your cell phone because
you have some time because you're parked
on the highway right and um somebody cut
you off
so you could automatically react go son
of a [ __ ] i can't believe he just did
that and just use all of this energy the
cortisol epinephrine adrenaline that's
flowing through your body and causing
stress in your body
or you can say well what if that person
just found out their dog died they're
really trying to get home quickly
okay i guess it's okay if she or he cut
in front of me right or they just got a
call from their mother their mother fell
yeah would you change the way you felt
about it and the answer is yeah probably
and the reason because you changed the
frame
so you can learn how to create frames
for yourself how you see the world how
you see failure how you see effort how
you see your habits how you create
frames in advance that actually serve
you
through awareness and response versus
reactivity
and that is what a lot of
people who
for example i'm going to go back to
professional athlete what do you learn
how to do
respond in a variety of different ways
in advance or through practice
so that when it's game time
you're just unconsciously doing what you
do is your financial governor
holding you back from doubling or
tripling your income in the next six to
12 months
now you may be asking john what in the
world is a financial governor
and i'll explain it this way
many years ago when the car companies
were building engines that were faster
and stronger and more resilient
cars could go 200 250 miles an hour some
maybe even to 300 miles an hour but
because of laws in europe and in the
united states these governors were put
on the engine so that the car even
though it can go faster and perform even
better
it was limited to about 155 miles per
hour so here we are we have these cars
that can go extremely fast but for
obvious reasons to conserve on gas to be
able to have more safety on the roads
and to keep us generally all driving
around the same speed limit we created
these governors to put on engines in
order to limit the speed at which the
car can go at well what does that have
to do with you earning more money you
accumulating more wealth and the answer
is everything
if you understand that you have a
conscious brain that wants to set goals
but you have a subconscious mind that is
going to limit your thoughts emotions
feelings and behaviors to what you are
governed by which is your subconscious
mind
then here's one of the things that we
have discovered
people who make thirty thousand dollars
a year or fifty or a hundred or five
hundred thousand dollars a year or a
million dollars a year or more
their financial governor is set at a
totally different setting than somebody
who's earning less
so
why does this make a difference well it
makes a difference because there's a
part of your brain that chooses the goal
that you want to achieve and there's
another part of your brain that's
responsible for everything else your
thoughts emotions feelings and behaviors
and so
if you don't have coherence between
these two parts of your brain if you
don't know how to remove the governor
and reset it
chances are you're going to have goals
and dreams financial ones and even
lifestyle ones that you're not going to
achieve not because you're not capable
of doing it it's just because you are
wired set conditioned programmed
whatever you want to call it to earn the
income you're earning right now and
maybe a little bit more each day each
week each month versus doubling or
tripler quintupling your income
now let me give you a different visual
for this that'll hopefully
cement what i mean let's say
you're in a room that has a thermostat
in there and the thermostat is set to a
nice and comfortable 70 degrees and you
feel nice at that temperature
what happens if you open up a window and
let's say it's winter and cold air comes
in
well what happens is the mechanism in
the thermostat that picks up what the
temperature is in the room
picks up a deviation that cold air has
come in the room and what does it do it
sends a signal through the electrical
system for the heater to go on so that
the room gets back to 70 degrees that's
called a cybernetic mechanism a control
and respond mechanism that occurs in
machines that we create them in
or in animals like us
so whether it's hot air coming into a
room or cold air coming into a room any
deviation from the set program
activates the air conditioning or the
heat until the program and the room are
one and the same
that is a cybernetic mechanism as i
mentioned and here's what happens in us
humans if you're used to earning thirty
thousand or fifty thousand seventy five
a hundred or two hundred or more or you
are used to a certain lifestyle any
deviation up or down from that setting
that comfort zone that programming
kicks in your nervous system so that you
either turn up the jets and earn more
based on what you're used to or if you
do really well for a week a month a
quarter you actually back off and
sabotage your success until you meet the
setting that you have in your mind that
is how a governor works in a car that's
how a governor works in your brain
so
if you want to double or triple your
income in the next six months 12 months
two years
doesn't it make sense that you should
reset your financial governor the
expectation point the programming the
conditioning
well of course it does
what i've seen
in my years of training whether it's
sales people or entrepreneurs or
individuals to make more money is the
ones that think that they could do it
just by gaining more knowledge
missed the point because it's a part of
our brain that gains more knowledge but
doesn't change behavior what you have to
do is reprogram your financial set point
your conditioning the expectation point
and when you do that and you create this
coherence between your goal and your
dream and your subconscious programming
that is when your behavior starts to
change that is when fears dissipate that
is when you stop procrastinating that is
when you take inspired action
and you don't sabotage the success that
you are achieving
so
in order to achieve your goals and
dreams you have to reset your governor
reset your financial thermostat am i
speaking to myself in a kind motivating
empathetic compassionate way
or am i consistently self-deprecating
and putting myself down i used to think
a lot like when i was younger i'm not
good enough i'm not smart enough i'm not
worthy
um those thoughts uh and you know lots
of fear fear of being embarrassed fear
of failure fear of being ashamed and i
still have the thoughts every once in a
while especially when i'm setting new
goals those come up holy mackerel they
come up so freaking fast
are you smart enough to achieve that are
you good enough to achieve that even
when i got into really diving deep into
the brain science and even my new book i
had i was petrified to release my book
it took me two years to write it because
now i'm entering another whole domain of
neuroscience and neuropsychology with
world-renowned experts that i've worked
with for years
but now here i am putting myself out
there with hey this is
neuroscientifically correct so i had to
make sure that it was
um and but there was a lot of fear
but i understand what the emotion of
fear is it's a subconscious trigger that
causes this feeling that i don't like
and it's a ghost signal for me not a
stop signal for me that's interesting
what do you mean by that
well fear is an emotion emotions are all
triggered at the subconscious level in
the past i used to teach and also do
visualize my goals
whether it's my body health
relationships money charity whatever i
used to visualize the outcome and some
of the latest research now shows
in addition to visualizing the outcome
visualize the obstacles
and in the past when we talk about this
law of attraction no don't visualize the
ops because you attract them to no no
your brain's way smarter than that
so if you have whether it's a belief
that's in your way
a story that's holding you back a
circumstance references it you know
something that's holding you back from
achieving x
so take a look at whatever it is that
you already know is holding you back i
don't believe i'm worthy i'm don't
believe i'm smart enough don't mean that
i'm good enough don't believe if i'm
skilled if i'm too young too old i'm i'm
to this or to that or not enough of this
not enough that so address that and say
okay here's an obstacle
i'm going to visualize that obstacle
being real i'm going to visualize just
moving it aside and me moving towards my
goal the very act of acknowledging that
releases the neural tension around if
you do that over and over and over again
what your brain starts to see is yes
there was a struggle and so it's worthy
of me creating this neural pattern
around this new effort right because
most of what we're doing is you know
we're being we're on autopilot
we're just eeking through the day you
know on autopilot and so the brain loves
anything that makes it curious the brain
likes anything novel the brain likes a
challenge so earlier you're asking me
about you know one of the brain training
companies other than ours he said does
it work i said yeah it's a workout for
your brain
and if you can strengthen the neural
patterns of you seeing yourself with an
obstacle and overcoming it what do you
think that does to your self confidence
and certainty builds it up
builds it up so if you'd if you actually
do
the work
and develop those patterns in your brain
as you're doing the stuff you need to do
in the physical world you just
strengthen those neural patterns and
that's what becomes your habits we are
consciously aware of feelings
that are triggered at the subconscious
level the feeling is the end point
of the human experience in the physical
body
and so when you have something in your
brain that that a neural network says
well
what if this book comes out and you fail
what if it's not good enough what is
scientifically not correct what if what
if what if my brain is going to process
that the same way as your brain and
everybody else because that's
everybody's brain is the same
the mechanism of how the brain works
it's einstein's brain hitler's brain
genghis khan's brain
tom billio's brain john acetate all the
same functionality
so if you understand the mechanics of
what's supposed to happen
then you say okay great when i feel this
then what am i going to do
so i like to use an analogy of a car
you're driving a car
and you're talking to a friend of yours
and a light pops up on the dash you
don't take a hammer and hit a light
it's a signal something's happening in
the in the in the engine in the trunk in
the in the tires something's happening
emotions and feelings aren't uh positive
or negative
they're
empowering or disempowering to varying
degrees if you don't understand them
and so if you think about fear right
how does a firefighter
go into a burning building
when there's this enormous adrenaline so
what does your morning routine look like
now
what what's you know so today was a
little bit different except for one
thing because i drove from san diego to
la to be with you but i wake up i pee i
do my meditation 20 to 30 minutes every
morning i don't care where i am in the
world during that time i i do a variety
of different meditations so there's
meditations that i can do where i'm just
observing my thoughts now a lot of
people think well i'm not supposed to
have thoughts when you meditate
says whom there's hundreds of different
ways to practice awareness see
meditation is the art of awareness
awareness internally
awareness externally but also the
various millions of layers that exist in
the physical and the non-physical world
so this morning i did a meditation with
some ocean sounds
and so it was
about five o'clock i woke up this
morning sat in my little sofa you know
with my feet propped up and did a 20-so
minute meditation in the dark with the
ocean just listening to the ocean just
paying attention and going into a
trance-like state
where
after two or three minutes i i
disappeared like my body was part of air
and space
so today was i was using sound to get
into that trance-like state other days
i'll do a mantra whether it's you know a
lot of people know transcendental
meditation so it's the all mantra so you
just take a deep breath in
and then as you exhale
[Laughter]
and the question is why would you do
that and the answer is anytime you can
give your brain a rhythm it will entrain
to that rhythm that's one
anytime you could pay attention to your
breath
inhale and exhale you turn off the
parasympathetic nervous system um you
could you turn on the parasympathetic
nervous system which is your rest and
relaxation and your calm state of flow
versus your sympathetic nervous system
which is the stress response system of
adrenaline norepinephrine cortisol etc
so when you get the serotonin oxytocin
and dopamine going
and you're in that state of calmness
you're able to enter deeper levels of
consciousness and awareness so you're
able to observe a thought you're able to
hear your heartbeat you're able to
sense different things that are giving
are being risen in your body through
thoughts that you're having so you can
actually start to see when i have this
thought here's the sensation in my body
and you start to get so
attuned to what's happening what stimuli
is happening within you that's producing
these sensations that cause you to
either take action or not retreat or
move forward you can start to get a feel
for how the mechanics work
so
so do that sometimes i'll put on some of
the tibetan monks and chant with them
so i use sound no sound i use breathing
i use open eye closed die five minutes
ten minutes thirty minutes so i practice
the art of being in control of my breath
not breathing just being one with the
entire universe and feeling this other
than
normal state of consciousness that we're
used to it's not sleep and it's not you
know conscious awareness you're in an
altered state of awareness and you can
you can
enter deeper and deeper and deeper
layers
of energy which everything is made up
anyway everything's connected we have
this obviously our physical body
but the space between you and i right
now there's just vibrating packets of
energy
right and so you're able to access
different layers of all of the
intelligence and information that
already exists in the universe versus
the memories that we have in our brains
and that's magical setting goals is an
intellectual and imagined exercise that
your conscious brain right i'm going to
show you one of the little brains today
from the sitting here on my house your
conscious brain
left prefrontal cortex specifically
where you get to choose
what is it you would love to have your
life be like
what is the imagination you know of the
ideal life that you'd like he says
everybody could do that
he says but achieving goals
happens as a result of having the right
beliefs perceptions habits
attitudes
at the non-conscious level
where all of the habits reside part of
the hippocampus part of your brain that
drives your automatic behavior day in
and day out is
what is going to determine whether you
achieve those goals or not he says using
willpower
to achieve goals
is like using gun powder it's just a
starter
using resilience or using your
imagination those are all really good
conscious abilities that anybody can use
he says but if you don't develop
the
habits at the non-conscious level which
include
your self-image for how you see your
life
you're never going to achieve those
goals awareness is what gives you choice
and choice is what gives you freedom
most people are living their lives in a
reactive state automatic reactive state
because of these set points that we
talked started talking about so we're in
this repetitive cycle over and over and
over and over we react to the same
things we behave the same way we eat the
same foods we dress the same way
just to maintain that homeostasis and
comfort zones and we've never been
taught like when were we taught as kids
like here are your six core emotions
here's the way you deactivate you know
your stress center or fear so here's how
you activate your imagination center
here's how you have more focus here's
how you develop a new belief here's how
you develop a new habit here's how you
release one we haven't been taught that
we've been told they're important things
but we haven't been given the tools
and then we haven't practiced the tools
enough to be able to make them part of
our unconscious competence brain
so how do you do some of those things i
mean that was a pretty extraordinary
list and i'll say
beliefs i was just thinking that a lot
of us are
you know consistently focusing on our
goals what do we want to achieve
what do we want to let go of who do we
want to become where do we want to go
who do we want to help
a lot of goals right what about
celebrations
have you considered that part of the
goal achieving process and part of how
you activate the reward center of your
brain is you focus also
on what is it that you've achieved up
until now what hurdles have you overcome
up until now
whenever we think about challenges that
we've faced that we've overcome whenever
we think about the lessons we've learned
from those challenges whenever we think
of
anything as simple as learning how to
ride a bike as a kid and learning how to
speak the languages that we speak and
learning how to do math and learning how
to cook and learning how to get dressed
and learning learning learning and doing
doing doing and accomplishing
accomplishing accomplishing any time we
think of those things
we're activating that same neural
network
and that reward center which actually
increases motivation
so when we remind ourselves of all the
things that we have done and
accomplished and overcome
we fuel
the future things that we must overcome
and the future things that we want to
accomplish so today
just before this beautiful weekend is um
you know gone
why not write a list of all the things
that you can think of
that you have overcome and you've
achieved and celebrate celebrate
celebrate celebrate replicate it
anywhere with billions of dollars
but we are getting some of the user's
manual now
so when you feel fear what should you do
i teach the first two inner sizes that i
teach every one of our students number
one is called take six calm the circuits
so if you have this unpleasant
anxious fearful emotion energy in motion
right and it's unpleasant and the breaks
have gone on
if you just take six deep breaths in
through your nose
out through your mouth like you're
breathing through a straw you will
deactivate the stress response center
which means blood is going to go back to
the left prefrontal cortex the einstein
part of the brain can actually think
through this problem because what
happens when the stress response center
is activated blood goes away from that
into the fear response so you have
epinephrine cortisol adrenaline to be
able to get you out of the situation
it's part of our instinctual brain part
of the reptilian brain the first part of
the brain that was developed was that
then the mammalian brain the limbic
system then the neocortex the thinking
brain
so when our brain has this signal of oh
my god you might get hurt you might lose
this you might get in trouble you might
be embarrassed or shamed ridiculed
judged et cetera
that part of the brain is going to get
activated so if you take six deep
breaths first calm down calm the
circuits first
then do inner size number two is called
aya aia
the first day is for awareness
what am i thinking right now what am i
feeling right now what am i sensing
right now
what is my behavior right now
to your thoughts feelings sensations
awareness of behavior what's my
intention right now that's the i
well my intention is to move forward i
want to do this
great what's one
very small action step that you can take
now the reason you want to take one
small action step
is one small action step
your brain can handle
if it's one small step towards it the
threat response goes away but if you
focus on the end game right away
you're going to get that rush and that
instant trigger of the fear response
stress response so the first thing you
want to do is learn how to manage your
mindset
and what you focus on learn how to
manage your emotions because they drive
your behavior more than anything else
because we move away from pain and we
move towards pleasure but we move away
from pain a thousand times faster
and pain wires in the brain faster for
survival mechanisms
so purely from a neuroscience
perspective just understanding self
once you understand okay this feeling is
normal okay what should i do
take six con the circuits
ayah
and now you can start being progressive
and make progress towards what you want
now while you're in the you know in the
uh what am i thinking feeling it's a
chance to be aware i was born in tel
aviv israel
and moved to montreal because my parents
were
tired of raising their kids in a worn
torn part of the world which was you
know in israel and the palestinian areas
i'm sure everybody felt that same way
that whole region my parents moved to
montreal from uh israel and at the time
i really had a hard time learning the
french and the english language
and i developed some
i guess self-esteem issues that i wasn't
smart enough or as good as the other
kids because i couldn't communicate uh
when i was really young and then i got
into a lot of trouble
uh as a
as a young teen from the age of 12 to 17
i got into a lot of trouble with the law
mostly because
i had low self-esteem if you can believe
that um
i did at the time we all have a story we
have a money story a relationship story
a health story we have a story for
everything and then that story keeps
recreating our lives over and over and
over again and we have beliefs that
support the story we have habits that
support the story we have people that
support the story we have systems that
support our story
and so my question i always ask people
who would you be with a different story
talk to me about set points that was
something really interesting in what you
talk about around the stories and things
that we carry that i found really
interesting we started to retrain our
agents brains after we did a we did a
an event
75 agents paid i think it was two or
three thousand dollars to go through a
six month brain retraining program
those 75 agents increased our sales by a
hundred million dollars wow and we said
okay we're going to teach this to the
entire company hey yeah so we went from
a billion two to four point five billion
in sales a year in three years
by working on this versus what they
needed to do i wanted to figure out if
the stuff that i did in the 80s when i
was a kid you know that broke free
would it work with some of my agents and
so we took 75 agents randomly agents
said hey do you want to get into a
six-month program too like retrain your
brain your subconscious brain
around your beliefs about what is
possible for you to achieve around your
habits of what you have to do in order
to achieve that
and we focused on retraining their
subconscious mind
and so for six months they had to go
through a process of listening to
certain audio tapes reading reading
certain materials every day and
following the process of training their
brain specifically their subconscious
brain which controls 95 to 98 of all of
our thoughts emotions and behaviors
today
and within six months that group
increased sales by 100 million dollars
jesus 100 million dollars and i said
holy [ __ ] right this is working
uh and so we started to teach some of
what we teach now in neurogym actually
now we have the technologies we have the
systems that are far better than what we
did back in the 90s and we went from 1.2
billion to 4.5 billion a year
and it wasn't because we taught them any
more skills to be real estate agents we
taught them how to change the way they
thought about themselves we taught them
how to change their habits
our agents who made 750 000 or more were
in front of a client 75 of the time
and we asked all the agents that weren't
in front of more clients like why are
you doing that like why aren't you in
front of people that are going to help
you earn more income oh well we're busy
doing this and doing this and doing this
and they had stories and excuses and
reasons why
and so part of the work that i love to
do now is is really help people
understand what is your story when i was
five six seven years old i moved from
israel to montreal i spoke hebrew but
not english or french and for two and a
half years i felt dumb
i felt like i wasn't smart enough and i
wasn't good enough and i was made fun of
as a kid
that led to me being involved in street
gangs from the age of 12 to 16. in
montreal in montreal wow
we traffic drugs from florida we did
break-in entries we we had a little
street gang about 12 of us that just
gone to a lot of trouble my path was
either jail or the morgue
one of the two
and uh there's a lot of successful
people that have that kind of a story
for some strange reason
um
and at 19 i met a mentor his name was
alan brown he was a real estate
developer still in montreal uh no this
was in i moved from montreal after years
of turbulence i finally broke free and
moved from montreal to toronto which is
about
350 miles in
yeah and um
may
1980 i took uh my real estate course
june 20th 1980 became licenses of real
estate age and the reason i did is i met
a man the weekend before that my brother
introduced me to
who was interpersonal development yeah
and he was into you know zig ziglar and
dennis waitley and brian tracy's you
know 35 years ago
and he introduced me to this world of of
you know the mind introducing me the
world of changing my beliefs changing my
habits changing my perceptions of first
who are you and he really helped me see
that
you know the spiritual greatness within
everybody the intelligence that's within
everybody he had me start with getting
in touch with that and
it was very philosophical and didn't
have the evidence that we have today
on
affirmations visualization meditation
mindfulness subliminal programming
habit creation in all of the
different methodologies that we've all
heard about whether it was the
astronauts that went to the moon
initially that trained their brains or
the musicians that have or the
athletes that do
the science now is just so phenomenal on
what is actually happening and so as i
was building my own companies
i built my companies by training my
employees not on the skills that they
needed but on how spectacular they were
as human beings
and the greatness was within them and if
they trained their brain to have the
belief that it is they may not have the
skill or the know-how but if you have
the belief that i can i will i must you
can build the habit you can build the
habit you can
if you think about this i don't care if
you if we asked any question on health
wealth relationships career business
spirituality we wanted to find the
answer to something yeah we could google
it and within minutes have everything we
want to know
everything tutorials videos audios how
to step by step blueprint color
coordinate whatever you want so our
problem isn't how to uh all the how-to
exists how to build a business exists
how to be a great lover exists you know
it all exists how to get in shape right
so i wanted to focus on you know how do
i help more people take more of the
action they know they should be and want
to like what will your life be like if
you had them right now what would your
family life be like you have to give
them a benefit that's greater than the
switch cost
that's interesting right so the switch
cost is something that our brain resists
the only human that likes change is a
wet baby
every other human being is resistant to
it because
safety first and homeostasis and energy
conservation so we are biologically
wired
not to want to change
so we have to deliberately coax the
brain into
motivational reasons emotional reasons
you have to have intrinsic reason why
must you do this
and so you can use pain as a frame as
well so if you don't then are you okay
with your life being like this at this
age in five years and 10 years and 20
years
and if you're okay with that then you're
not a candidate for change
but if you're committed to letting go of
the old so you can create the new
and you create motivations every day
that's where the power is remember
earlier progress not perfection so
anybody can do
one minute or
10 seconds so if you can start to
formulate a habit a daily habit a weekly
habit
it doesn't matter how long it is
if you can create that space in your
brain that on this day at this time this
is what i do and you do that repeatedly
that becomes a habit and it takes those
66 days or so for a simple habit
that you have to consciously do
to then the habit doing you
and that's why they say we are all
creatures of
habit because habits run their
themselves their subconscious programs
just run themselves for the last you
know 35 years you know what i've been
doing
is
i've had coaches for
skill training i've had coaches and
mentors for mindset training i've had
coaches on brain training i've had
coaches for business skills and training
i've had coaches and mentors and experts
for every different area of my life
whether it's health nutrition
business money investing getting out of
debt making more money protecting your
assets there are experts for every
single area of our lives that already
know
what you need to do
a belief is nothing more than a group of
cells
that have been connected and then
reinforced
and we have two types of beliefs we have
beliefs that whatever really fast i'm
going to stop you there because that's
so important yeah and so different than
i would have expected i think when
people hear belief it is believing
something that is true
which did not enter into your definition
no we we believe
whatever we believe is truth for us but
it's not the truth
that's really interesting right but we
have been conditioned
if we go back a little bit to
what we talked about earlier about you
know when you were a baby when you were
born what belief did you have
zero goose egg zero not one
and so you learned what to believe and
how to even formulate your beliefs
chances are from parents
teachers
brothers sisters television maybe when
you read some books
right and we behave based on what we
believe
so we might be behaving our lives away
based on false or inaccurate or
disempowering beliefs
so if a belief is a neural pattern in
the brain
then we probably have some good ones
empowering ones useful ones and chances
are we have some that are not useful not
empowering and not worthy of the
geniuses that we all are
so the question is
is it possible for me to develop
new beliefs that i don't believe right
now
the answer is yeah
yes what does that process look like
so
the process is you can read new beliefs
to life
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
amazing mel robbins motivation check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there adopt a simple habit
every single morning i do a very simple
thing i write down five things that i
want that's it when i start my day after
i get up on the alarm rings i make my
bed i pull on my exercise clothes i set
an intention